okay real quick i don't have a ton of
time for this particular story but i
think it's an important one to mention
we have a situation right now where the
republican party is blaming biden for
everything
but actively blocking solutions and this
might not really be a shock to you it's
like hey david yeah welcome to american
politics particularly republican
politics they're blaming joe biden for
the high gas prices but just about every
republican or every republican voted
against the crackdown on gas price
gouging they're blaming joe biden for
the baby formula shortage but they voted
against a deal
uh that was a bill that would actually
deal with the shortage and now they're
saying put us in power in november and
it's terrifying but they have a pretty
good chance at taking over so a couple
of different articles here to look at
first of all
full list of 192 house republicans who
voted against the fda baby formula bill
okay the house last week
passed a 28 million emergency spending
bill to address the baby formula
shortage
it passed 231 to 192
mostly along party lines all house
democrats supported it only 12
republicans did
and 192 republicans voted against it hey
here's a problem they claim to want to
solve it if you look at for example
elise stefanix she's a republican
congresswoman you look at her twitter
joe biden owns this baby formula crisis
she's posting pictures of babies she's
doing all these actually that might just
be a picture of her own birth
announcement yeah that is that has
nothing to do with baby formula but if
you scr if you not directly anyway if
you scroll down her twitter you see gas
now at historic high energies uh biden's
energy crisis joe biden never should
have let the baby formula crisis reach
this point and then they vote against
the bill that would deal with it
you look at the gas prices there was a
bill passed by the house to deal with
gasoline price gouging it passed 217 to
207 with no republicans voting for it
and also four democrats voting against
it they complained that democrats do
nothing they blame biden for problems
democrats put together bills to actually
deal with some of these issues and they
vote against them and sometimes they'll
say well the bill wasn't perfect and of
course no bill is but this is not really
just a problem of republicans what
republicans are doing is unconscionable
but we have to also say
where is the democratic communications
arm it's like it's non-existent there's
no coherent messaging there's no
coherent marketing in pr strategy
republicans are active actively
sabotaging
baby formula gas prices all of these
problems that there's at least an idea
of how to not fix permanently but
improve upon
and republicans are getting in the way
of all of it and unfortunately democrats
are not coherently united with a
cohesive strategy to say look at what
they're doing
look at what they're doing one last
thing there's a lot of criticism of how
despite controlling the senate democrats
can't get a lot of stuff passed i think
it's important to understand that when
most things need 60 votes in the senate
if you have 50
you don't really control it sure you
control the agenda and if there's a tie
on something that you need 51 votes for
kamala harris can can make that 51st
vote but when you need 60 votes it's a
bit of a misnomer number to say you
control the senate you can control the
agenda uh and i think that that's an
important thing to keep in mind
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video